Formed MK party may become a heavy hitter
and even kingmaker after the elections
or that's if recent by elections are anything to go by.
The party took a gamble and uh
competed uh
in elections in Nimbu,
Malang and Guazulu Nadal
but the risk paid off
with the party taking 28% off the vote.
Political analyst
Wayne Sussman says the party is eating off both a and C
and E F F plates.
This is a significant result
cause we had seen up until now that m K
could be competitive in Kwazulu Natal.
This was their first foray beyond Kwazulu Natal
of course the province where Jacob Zuma hails from
and this by election was in the High Felt Ridge area in
uh in the governing Becky township
and MK beat the E F
F for second place.
They got 28% of the vote.
Yes, this township is a majority Zulu speaking township
but this is a great sign that MK can do well.
Maybe they'll do well nationally
but right now
from the data we've seen
they're gonna do well in Kwazulu Natal
and can do very well in Zulu speaking areas
of which there many uh
in Mpumalanga and Sirtni Kharteng.
So m K is Sirtni
a party to watch.
So what does this mean?
Because as you said,
the majority was thinking yes,
Guazulu Natal is a given because of the Jacob Zuma
uh connection
but now with Mpumalanga having polled so well for them
How would they then poll nationally,
do you think?
Well, we gonna start seeing opinion poll soon.
I know E N C
a will be soon be releasing its poll.
My gut feel a few weeks ago is 3,
4%. Maybe they'll be the 5th or 6th biggest party.
But if they can,
remember there are a lot of, uh,
there are a lot of voters in Harding and in Pumalanga
and of course
Kwazulu Natal.
If they rarely start, um,
catching fire,
they can do well in the selection and rarely disrupt.
And let's also remember that yes,
m K is going to take away votes from the a N C.
But so far we've seen that they're also hurting the E F,
F because they can do that radically economic
transformation,
uh, I, um, type of politics as well,
if not better than the E f, f.
That's the way some votes are seeing it.
They also gonna affect the IFP
because they can do traditional Zulu, uh,
identity politics as well.
Or in some sense, uh,
Zuma did it much better in his
leading the ANC than the IFP.
So this party is threatening many established player.